all these years after his accidental
death in March 1993 Brandon Lee
continues to fascinate fans both new and
old son of martial arts legend Bruce Lee
the actor is best known for his truly
haunting performance in the goth tinge
1994 film The Crow I see the major
decision now see you enforce it here's
everything you need to know about
Brandon Lee in 1992 Brandon Lee told
deseret news I've always wanted to be an
actor from the time I was really young
it's just what I've always wanted to do
but it was never my idea to become a
martial arts action actor from a very
young age Brandon was trained in his
father's own unique style of kung fu'
jeet kune do-- which incorporates a mix
of martial arts techniques as Brandon
said in a 1992 interview I started
training with my dad really as soon as I
could walk I mean my dad was a really
diligent trainer according to
Entertainment Weekly Brandon could
destroy a wooden board with a single
kick by the time he was 6 years old
meanwhile people were constantly
training with Bruce at home making for
quite the unusual childhood I remember
when I was a little kid a lot of my
friends didn't want to come over to the
house because there were always these
men out in the backyard screaming and
breaking things you know Brandon was
only eight at the time of his father's
passing in 1973 following Bruce's death
the surviving leaves returned to Los
Angeles where Brandon struggled to find
his place he was kicked out of two high
schools and dropped out of a third after
earning his GED he went on to study
theater at Emerson College for a year
before attending the famous Lee
Strasberg theatre and Film Institute in
New York as he started getting more
deeply involved with acting his life
began to flow like water according to
The Hollywood Reporter Brandon turned
down the opportunity to play his dad in
the 1993 biopic dragon the Bruce Lee
story as Lee explained I was a little
scared by the whole thing really
it's strange to play your own father you
know I couldn't really wrap my mind
around it that makes sense if he'd
played his dad he would have had to
feign a romantic relationship with a
woman pretending to be his mom Linda
which would have been awkward
actor Jason Scott Lee ultimately went on
to play Bruce in the film but
opportunity came knocking for Brandon in
1985 when he was cast in the television
film kung fu the movie starring
alongside veteran actor David Carradine
on the whole it's very dramatic stuff a
coward
a peasant carries vegetables an old
woman who runs in the night from shadows
soon enough he began popping up in more
and more action films in 1985 Brandon
Lee made his first and only film in Hong
Kong legacy of rage even though the film
was in Cantonese Hollywood quickly took
notice of the young star since he was as
talented and photogenic as his father it
wasn't long before Brandon landed his
first english-language leading role in
1989's entirely miscible laser mission
curiously the action film also starred
acting legend Ernest Borgnine but it's
definitely not one of his most
distinguished performances you're fond
of birds by the early 90s wheeze star
was on the rise
in 1991 he starred in showdown in Little
Tokyo which co-starred Dolph Lundgren of
rocky for fame alright say it Asian task
force your Kenner Nelson sent me thanks
to that film Lee was subsequently
offered a three-picture deal one of
those films happen to be the action
flick rapid-fire but it was his haunting
and emotional performance in Alex Proyas
as the crow that made his career earning
him a cult following that continues to
grow to this day unfortunately the young
actor wouldn't live long enough to enjoy
that success Brandon Lee had a
reputation as a reckless daredevil as
his former fiancee Eliza Hutton
explained to people in 1992 he's
confident intense indirect and a lot of
people find that intimidating in fact
Lee was so confident he often wrote his
harley-davidson motorcycle with no
helmet in his hands off the handlebars
he once said if I want to put my head in
a brick wall it's my business
he even owned a Cadillac hearse and used
to joke that it was good for taking on
camping trips in an interview with Jay
Leno in 1992
he talked about coming home to find a
burglar in his home instead of calling
the police he confronted the robber who
lunged at him with a knife and cut his
arm the two fought and Lea finally
called the cops after he separated the
thief's shoulder and broke his arm the
police came and took him away and after
he got out of the hospital he got two
years for breaking and entering in a
temper it just goes to show that Lea was
a major risk taker both on screen and
off he could be super intense when
making movies for example Brandon used
his method acting training to prepare
for the crow by soaking in a tub full of
ice that way he could feel how called
eric draven must have been while lying
in his grave a producer berated him for
this dangerous stunt and told him to
mind his health though it's hard to
imagine anyone else in the role Brandon
Lee wasn't the first choice to play Eric
Draven in the crow at first producers
wanted to cast an actual musician for
the role of the murdered indie rocker
names like Michael Jackson and Charlie
Sexton were kicked around before the
team realized there wouldn't be as much
singing or performing as originally
planned
even then Lee's name wasn't at the top
of the list comic book writer James O
bar wanted Johnny Depp to play the dark
superhero but in the end Brandon Lee's
martial arts experience and his
smoldering good looks won in the role
sometimes he was heavily involved with
the film even before shooting began
according to the independent he also
helped shape the story convincing
director Alex Proyas to remove a subplot
because of its problematic Asian
stereotyping
according to co-star Jon Polito
conditions on the set of The Crow were
terrible Lee reportedly lost 20 pounds
while filming plus the dark tale of
revenge and murder was mostly filmed at
night in North Carolina's freezing
winter conditions Lee was constantly
getting drenched in water and filming
was constantly interrupted to fix his
makeup
we reportedly filed a formal complaint
against production conditions mere days
before his death
in fact things were so rough that his
manager called producers in a rage
accusing them of trying to kill Lee
during the scene in which Eric Draven
crashes through the glass door of a pawn
shop Lee was cut badly by the prop class
prompting Pulido to express concern
about all the physical risks his co-star
was taking all sorts of onset injuries
occurred during shooting speaking to
Inside Edition in 1993 an anonymous crew
members stopped just short of saying the
shoot was haunted nothing ever seemed to
go right that definitely was some bad
vibes on a set one crew member
reportedly drove a screwdriver through
his hand by accident another member was
severely burned after the crane he was
operating came into contact with power
lines a stuntman reportedly fell through
the roof of a set during rehearsal
breaking a number of ribs meanwhile a
series of hurricanes tore through North
Carolina during filming destroying a
number of the Crowes sets but the most
tragic accident was yet to come
on March 31st 1993 Brandon Lee was
accidentally shot in the abdomen by
co-star Michael Massey with an
improperly loaded prop gun they were
filming the scene in which Eric Draven
comes home to find his fiancee being
assaulted the tip of a dummy bullet a
mock round used in close-ups was lodged
in the barrel in front of the blank when
Massey pulled the trigger the blanks
sent the fragment flying tragically it
lodged in the actor's spine and after
six hours of surgery Brandon Lee died in
Wilmington North Carolina
he was just 28 years old his death was
ruled an accident by negligence contrary
to popular belief Brandon Lee's death is
never seen in the final cut of the film
what we do see in the finished movie is
a body double Brandon Lee's mother Linda
and fiance Eliza Hutton were both in
favor of director Alex Proyas finishing
the crow however Linda filed a lawsuit
against the production company naming 13
people at fault for her son's wrongful
death the lawsuit was eventually settled
out of court
sadly Lee and Eliza Hutton were set to
be married just a couple of weeks from
the day he died
when Brandon Lee died he still hadn't
filmed all his scenes for The Crow as we
mentioned earlier filmmakers he was the
body double to finish the film in fact
it was future John wick creator director
chads2 he'll ski who was hired as the
stand-in for Li Sahel ski filmed all of
Lee's remaining scenes and Lee's face
was subsequently superimposed over his
own in post-production the famous face
painting scene was one of the most
expensive scenes to complete since Lee's
face had to be digitally inserted into
the broken mirror seven years after his
death Brandon Lee could be seen in a
brief cameo role in the 2000 Swedish
film Sex Lies and video files the film
is a very low-budget hard-to-find horror
movie satire about a young man who loves
watching violent films this truly
bizarre Oh movie references loads of
classic pictures including alien a
Clockwork Orange and Robocop somehow
even Mel Brooks makes a cameo and so
does Brandon Lee in his very brief
appearance Lee plays of a fuddled
pedestrian who's clearly seen some very
hardcore stuff go down before Bruce Lee
died of a cerebral edema in 1973 the
martial arts star had two kids
Brandon and Shannon today Shannon Lee is
his sole remaining child and she's doing
everything she can to preserve the
memories of both her father and her
brother she runs the Bruce Lee
Foundation and oversees movies and
documentaries about her dad's life in
2018 on the 25th anniversary of Brandon
Lee's death Shannon appeared on the
Bruce Lee podcast to talk about her
beloved Big Brother she even shared some
of Brandon's journal entries for the
first time during the podcast Shannon
talked about how Brandon would often
prank her but when it came down to it he
was her fiercest defender Shannon
recalls the time her aunt
tried to force her to stop using her
comfort blanket just after Bruce Lee's
death Brandon just like stood up for me
so like he went he like put his hands on
his hips and was yelling long story
short Brandon triumphantly got Shannon's
blankie back what a great brother
Shannon also talked about Brandon's love
of reading and books he was apparently
quite fond of curling up with a
dictionary to look up words he didn't
know he knew the definition a
everything brandon was a born showman -
as a kid he'd write down episodes of the
twilight zone by hand and performed them
at school sadly Shannon was supposed to
be the best man at her brother's wedding
but that never came to pass Brandon Lee
is still loved and missed by his family
friends and fans buried next to his
father in Seattle's Lakeview Cemetery
the site has become a shrine to both
legends and it's visited by fans from
around the world people leave flowers
notes and other memorabilia to pay their
respects to the father and son who
touched so many people's lives through
their work reflecting on the crow
twenty-five years later The Saturday
Evening Post wrote that the film
captured the angst of a generation as
Roger Ebert wrote in his 1994 review of
the film it is a sad irony that this
film is not only the best thing Brandon
Lee accomplished but is actually more of
a screen achievement than any of the
films of his father Bruce Lee every time
someone watches The Crow they help
ensure that Brandon's unique legacy
lives on can't rain all the time check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]